haha the Joe Rogan experience there's
always gonna be something yep you know
what I mean but to me when a hate is
involved with it you know I think that's
where we should draw the line but that's
that's more of where I'm going is like
how many people from us like where it's
just you don't just kill random people
jogging down the street you know it's
hard it's it's hard to imagine that that
still goes on today right but then when
you hear about your dad and that your
dad went to college in a place where you
couldn't eat the same places as white
people you like white on campus on
campus yeah campus in his lifetime it's
changing it's getting better right that
doesn't exist today and this is what I
don't like and some black people I don't
want to say just black people but some
black people when they go ah you know my
dad hears this and he always gets mad
about it because when they when some
black people go it's no better than it
was way back in the day but there goes
excuse me you're 25 years old saying
that where I went through the [ __ ] right
it is a lot better a lot better I'm in
my house I can go to any restaurant I
want you know that interracial
relationship doesn't mean anything
anymore no I mean those people to most
people most people don't care at all and
that's the whole thing is that my dad is
like some black people discredit the
whole journey because they try to just
say ah it's just like it was before no
no yes not read any of Steven Pinker's
work mm-hmm
Steven Pinker is a really really
brilliant guy and one of the things that
he gets criticized for is showing how
much less violent the world is today
how much less crime there is how much
less rape how much less murder and this
is essentially the safest place the
safest time ever in human history and in
people like your dis discrediting all of
the horrors that happen he's like no not
no no I'm not I'm not dismissing all the
terrible things that happen in the world
but we're saying even though those
things do exist they exist at a far less
frequent time far less far less
frequently then did a hundred years ago
200 years ago and any time throughout
human history there's a trend and that
trend as a society is getting safer
people are getting nicer and people are
getting there
they're getting better like we're
growing and learning well I also think
now like I'm from my family my dad side
I'm the first person that dealt with
look like I would say I deal with racism
but not on the scale my dad dealt with
it not and my dad didn't deal with it on
the scale his father my grandfather
dealt with it so it's kind of like and
I'm teaching my kids not to be that way
so I feel like these kids that are young
growing up they're gonna be so much more
sensitive towards other people yeah then
we were for sure because we were still I
wouldn't say like in it in it but we
were in it like in my household you know
what I mean like my dad you know would
tell me stories of what happened to him
and I was like wow you went through that
but I went to a school in Houston Texas
where I stood out my parents were the
only mixed couple I was the only mixed
kid at our school like I believe because
I didn't it wasn't even a thing you know
like people go you look different like
kids would come up to me go what are you
and I were like mom what am I my dad was
like telling you black and Asian you
know so it's it's what I was but nobody
on my block we're interracial is either
black couples or white couples and my
parents were like like before the trend
you know and it's a thing where I saw
what happened to my mom didn't teach me
to be my mom didn't teach me anything
about my Korean heritage because people
made fun of her accent so she didn't
want me to go through that so she tried
to Americanize me as fast as possible
you know my dad he's that I don't give a
[ __ ] guy you know he's like there's
ignorant people
I don't care they can say what they want
you know his favorite word is the n-word
you know what I mean so he loves the
watch move my dad is so crazy he loves
to watch movies with the n-word in it
because he says that's real that's how
it really was I think that Leonardo
DiCaprio movie with samuel l.jackson the
band of eight or something like that it
was called flee hateful eight favorite
movie he goes cuz that's how you used to
in were like they said it that normally
like he loves the realness of that you
know so he's just crazy like he's 75
through some [ __ ] yeah it's a different
world different world that he went
through this is one thing that I went
you know people complain about social
justice warriors and the ridiculous
calling out of everything being racist
and everything being sexist and I agree
but the fact that that is the trend that
a lot of these young people are going in
there's it's too far in a lot of ways
but it'll all balance out like you've
got to have that sort of overwhelming
left-leaning ideology and then it's
overwhelming right-leaning ideology for
people to see what is rational yeah
what's rational but the trend seems to
be in a positive way like it seems to
all be going in a positive way like it
seems to be like racism is way less
tolerated amongst most of the people
that are in the middle most of people
that aren't crazy and aren't aren't you
know aren't overly sensitive like it
seems like things are balancing out
[Applause]